[Music]
welcome to the trivia and easter egg
show
i'm your host definition and this is
where we break down the top 10 trivia
tidbits and easter eggs from all the
latest movies and tv shows
this episode we're discussing spider-man
far from home which is filled to the
brim with references
easter eggs and call back surprise
movies that really make the film stand
out there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you don't want anything about the
film ruined then i highly recommend that
you turn off now
with that out the way i'm your host
definition and let's get into my
breakdown of the top 10 trivia and
easter eggs in spider-man far from home
number 10 amazing cameos spider-man far
from home is filled to the brim with
some amazing cameos that beautifully
link back to prior movies
the first one comes in the form of a
stock scientist who worked for obadiah
stain in the initial iron man film
the actor playing the part of an
engineer in the first film peter
billingsley
two returns to reprise his role after
his appearance over 11 years ago
also i had no idea that this was the kid
from a christmas story
this guy shaved a horseshoe into his
head for this role
that's dedication for you in addition to
this jk simmons returns as jay jonah
jameson
however the film gives him an update and
rather than having him as a newspaper
editor
the character is an alex jones-esque
reporter that breaks to the world that
spider-man is none other than peter
parker which ties into our next point
number 9 peter parker's identity whilst
the reveal that peter parker is
spider-man seems pretty big in the mcu
this reveal has actually already
happened in the civil war comic book
with the character unmasking on live tv
for the world in order to try and get
the other superheroes to sign up to the
registration act though we've already
had the civil war arc in the movie
this reveal definitely dealt out some
big consequences for the character
with the villains of the marvel universe
going against peter's friends and family
this included aunt may who was shot by a
hitman hired by kingpin
number eight finding wakanda on the nine
hour flight to europe when searching for
something to watch peter stumbles across
a documentary called finding wakanda
this shows that the country has
definitely opened its borders to the un
and has allowed access to the rest of
the world as promised at the end of the
film
black panther number seven iron heart
there's also a play on the hero iron
heart
in a documentary that appears here
called heart of iron
for those who don't know iron heart took
over the role of iron man when the
character died in the comic books and
this is a nice little hint at what we
may be getting in the future
number six benjamin franklin parker even
though we've never seen uncle ben in the
mcu
there's still a hint to him in this film
that comes in the form of the suitcase
that peter packs his clothes into
on the top next to the handle we can see
the initials bfp
which stands for benjamin franklin
parker peter's deceased uncle that set
him on the route to becoming a hero
number five london bridge in the film
when flying to take mysterio head on for
the final battle
happy hogan who is piloting the plane
drops a line about nick fury telling him
to go to london
bridge which he realizes is in fact
tower bridge
i don't know if this is for deafne but
i'm pretty sure
it's a joke about the song london bridge
by fergie
in which the singer unintentionally
references the wrong bridge for the
entire song and yet
she comes across like an idiot if you
know anything about london
so i kind of feel like this is a little
jab at that but whether it is i guess
we'll never know
number four peter's passport in the
movie peter parker's passport lists his
birthday as august 10th
which just so happens to be two days
after mine by the way and this is
significant because spider-man's first
appearance was in amazing fantasy 15
which was released on august 10 1962
number three jake gyllenhaal jack
gyllenhaal is actually no stranger to
spider-man films
and after toby maguire seriously injured
his back during the filming of
seabiscuit
gyllenhaal was almost recast as the
central character
because no one thought that he would be
able to film the movie maguire's back
did heal and he was able to go on and
shoot the sequel
which has an in-joke about his back
being heard when he falls during a
failed swing
number two ned and betty in the film
peter's guy in a chair ned ends up
getting pretty close to betty
and the two become boyfriend and
girlfriend though this is really
short-lived it's actually a reference to
the comics in which betty brandt and the
hobgoblin
ned leeds got wed though ned definitely
isn't a villain this is a cool little
reference to when the two tied the knot
that in the film shows their future
would have disastrous consequences if
they continued on their relationship
and finally number one the elementals
appearance
when the elementals appear there are
several references to spider-man's rich
comic history
in the film's opening there is a car
license plate which reads 463 which is
an easter egg for the earth film the
sandman
who first appeared in amazing spider-man
4 which released in 1963.
during the water elemental attack a boat
sign reads asm
which refers to the amazing spider-man
issue 2-1-2
which was the first appearance of water
villain hydro man
during the fire elemental attack there's
a license plate that reads 2865
sep which is a reference to the
spider-man villain molten man
who made his debut in the amazing
spider-man 28
back in 1965. and that's our top 10 list
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on these easter eggs and if you spotted
any other ones in the film that deserve
to be here
then make sure you comment below and let
me know if you love this video 3000 then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out my breakdown of mysterio
from the film which will be linked at
the end
it covers the character's entire
biography and is definitely worth
checking
out if you want to know more about the
enigma egg quentin beck i'll leave that
linked after this and hopefully i'll see
you over there soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe thanks again for taking
the time to watch this i've been
definition
you've been the best and i'll see you
next time take care
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you